the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we'll start today sorry I have a bit
of a sore throat hoarse voice I was
talking a lot this weekend okay
also today we're gonna do jacks and
malleability segregated witness and I'm
endorsing Nico for the first time ever
publicly and it's an intermittent cookie
offering so if you guys want cookies
it's an it's an airdrop and that you
just you just get them all right yeah so
yes it's a so I see my first I see oh
I'm endorsing okay so value bility so
malleability is the ability to deform
under pressure for material right
and so bitcoin is model off gold which
is the most malleable metal you can make
gold leaf and stuff so clearly we need
to design Bitcoin to be malleable right
I'm joking
okay actually in the correct context of
cryptography we're calling malleability
when it's it's not super hard definition
but it started with ciphertext where if
you can modify a ciphertext and that
modification will carry over into the
plaintext when it's still cryptid it
also applies to sort of messages and
signatures in our case signatures can be
malleable which means you can change the
signature and it's still a valid
signature so you know given a signature
s1 on message on message m1 you modify
the signature to s2 or you do that like
S Prime and it still signs the same
message it still validates it's true so
when we were defining signatures this
wasn't really an attack we'd considered
right if you know there's still a
signature right and you can't Forge a
signature but you can you know dot an
eye or something and the signature is
slightly different you can't create one
yourself but given a valid signature you
can make a slightly different valid
signature that's how it works in Bitcoin
in the Bitcoin signing algorithm but
there's all sorts of different kind you
know context where malleability exists
in cryptography and then part of it is
the admins thing
things still have to work for whatever
definition so so if you maleate a
signature and it no longer validates
well that's sort of a trivial like yeah
sure you can do that to any any bunch of
bytes you can just flip some of them and
and the whole thing doesn't work anymore
that's easy but it has you know
properties where it still works so so
this leads to some weird stuff in
Bitcoin where you can change a
transaction and it's still valid and
that's generally not what you want right
when you're signing if you've got some
kind of contract or some kind of payment
and you write a check you don't want
someone to be able to modify the check
and still be able to cash it right and
this can be you probably can I don't
really use checks much but like they
draw the line right like $100 and then
they like draw a line so someone doesn't
write and $0.99 there's something after
not that that's like the greatest attack
ever but um or 100 and then someone was
like thousand dollars I don't know but
but it's sort of like that where someone
can change the thing you signed can
change the thing you are agreeing to
after the fact and it's still valid and
it does something you don't expect okay
so so a review of the transaction format
which should be probably in people's
minds if you're looking at the homeworks
the problem set and one thing to focus
on is that the outputs don't look like
the inputs right these are fundamentally
different things right the outputs
specify a transaction ID and an index
and sorry the inputs and then the
outputs specify a script in an amount
there's there's another four byte field
here that doesn't matter but so
basically you're spending from a
transaction and they sort of row and
you're spending to just this arbitrary
pub key but you're not spending from a
pub key and you're not spending to a
transaction right you don't identify
your you know transaction itself here so
so this is constantly in almost every
website that shows blockchains is that
it gets this wrong so if you look at
like I don't know blockchain on info is
the probably the most popular
um and you just look at a transaction
okay so you look at a block and then you
look at a transaction in the block no
you go okay so you look at the
transaction yeah it shows you know this
address is sending to these two
addresses and brought chayo Dafoe is
particularly egregious and that there
may actually be more than one input and
two outputs in this transaction no just
they they like hide change transactions
away anyway so it looks like hey here
you know this address had some money in
it and it sent it to these two addresses
and if I click oh where did this money
come come from one a Tec easy and it
shows here's the Bitcoin address and oh
it's it's got multiple money you know
multiple transactions this addresses
have been involved in this is not how
Bitcoin works right they are running
their own sir you know database and sort
of making up this view of the network
which is incorrect transactions don't
send from an address
they send from another transactions
previous output and this is very
confusing because in the case let's say
in this transaction right there is a
what is it seven six seven six seven
something right so it's it says yeah
it's coming from one 8e whatever and if
I click on it I get three different
transactions there is a specific
transaction that one e-180 II was
involved in that is being spent from in
this transaction I can look it up
because I have an actual full node so if
I say get raw transaction and I put it
in here and I can see okay it was
spending from C 8 3 8 you know spending
from this transaction not just an
address so it's it's it's really I mean
if you're if you're coming at this sort
of new it's like okay fine why you you
know when you keep talking about this
but if you've been working on these
things a lot of people myself included
for like six months a year
I looked at these websites and I'm like
oh this is how it works and then it
would you know I don't six months in or
something looking to go to like wait huh
like this code is wrong but no this is
the Bitcoin code that actually is
running and so it's it's a weird thing
to sort of get used to like no you're
not spending from address you you don't
show the address at all when you spend
from it you spend from a specific output
okay so so that leads to some weird
issues specifically what gets signed so
to some extent you're signing the whole
transaction right you sign you want to
sign everything when you when you're
saying I'm sending money from here I'm
sending it to here you want to like make
sure that you're your signature covers
the entire transaction so that people
can't add stuff after remove stuff so
you want to sign the inputs and outputs
what the inputs contain signatures and
you can't sign the signature right
that's that doesn't make any sense
that's the signature is the thing you're
putting on at the end so it's sort of
weird right you've got this document and
you have a little line at the bottom for
the signature but should the signatures
be maybe a separate page that refers to
the previous page you know it's actually
kind of a weird confusing problem so in
practice in Bitcoin what Satoshi did and
you know 2009 you you take the whole
transaction but you remove the signature
fields you basically zero them out just
put a zero there and then you sign that
that sort of signature less transaction
and then you put that signature in after
the fact right and so that means if you
change any bit of the stuff that gets
signed other than the signature the
signature will break right so does that
make sense right you sort of have these
you know you have these empty lines kind
of and the idea is you you empty them
out you make them blank lines and then
you take that whole message hash it
including the empty parts and then paste
in those signatures after you've signed
you actually you don't and you don't
empty out that every line the line that
you're specifically putting the
signature in you actually put different
few bytes in there which leads to other
problems that I can maybe
I've done what so this seems okay right
it's like well look I'm I can't sign the
signatures sure but if you change any
bit of the stuff I'm signing the
signatures now break so this seems
perfectly safe right no one can change
the amounts I'm sending no one can
change where I'm sending it to I'm no
one contains where I'm sending from
right all these things get covered in my
signature so I'm good problem the
transaction ID the way you refer to
transactions is the hash of the whole
thing it the TX ID does not zero out the
the signature fields so the the identity
of the transaction itself the way to
point to and indicate where you're
spending from that includes the
signatures so that also seems like well
that's okay right when I point to
something I'm indicating the whole
transaction the whole signed transaction
so but the problem is that can change
right the signature itself may be
malleable and in Bitcoin it is there's
third party malleability problems so the
simplest one was leading zeros but all
these things are numbers you could say
okay someone's got a signature it's
these this big long string of bytes I'm
just gonna put zeros in the front I'm
gonna put a zero byte in the front of it
and that doesn't change the meaning
right if someone says I'm sending you
you know I'm sending you you know one
thousand dollars and I put a zero in
front of the one in 1,000 won't still a
thousand however for the the purpose of
a hash function if you have a zero byte
in front that changes the whole hash and
so they got rid of this pretty early
they sort of you know made it so that
you had to have the exact right number
number you can't have any leading zeros
but um the first one was just so I put
put a zero in the front the the harder
one is called low s where part of the
ECDSA signature scheme I showed before
that like it's this curve that's
symmetric about the y axis x axis
whether the the thing you're indicating
is on top of the curve or it's sort of
reflection on the bottom it's valid
either way so for any given signature
there's another signature that will be
valid you just sort of flip it make a
negative or positive
so so now there's a standard okay you
need to have highest right low s
signatures should be invalid both of
these are really tricky because they're
third-party malleability anyone can just
listen on the network see a transaction
change the signature and in doing so
they will change the TX ID which is how
all the software refers to transactions
so it looks like a new transaction to
all - most of the software and the
transactions are still valid the
signatures are still valid and you're
not sure which one we'll get in
there's also first party malleability or
in some cases second party if you're
doing transactions with multiple people
signing so I'm not gonna go back into
the elliptic curve signature algorithms
but there is a nuts right there's
randomness that you inject into the
signing process it's not a it's not
deterministic it's not that give it a
message and my private key I always
compute the same signature no that's not
how I work there are signature schemes
like that but in the case of the
elliptic curve stuff that Bitcoin uses
you have to make up a random number to
make each signature and no one knows
what that random number is so you could
use you can make up different random
numbers you can make as many signatures
as you want so given us given a message
and your private key you can make
whatever arbitrary number of signatures
there are all different signatures but
they're all valid signatures there is a
sort of standard for how to make them
the right way not randomly it's
basically take the hash of your private
key and the message being signed you
know put them together hash that and use
that as your random number because then
the idea as well it's it's got secret
information in it as well as the message
specific information in it so no one's
gonna be able to guess what it is so and
it's still kind of message dependent so
it'll change you time so there is that
but that's that's something you can do
that's a it's a really good idea because
if you if you use a non random K if
someone can guess K or if your random
number generator is broken they can
steal all your money they can forget you
know figure out your private key but um
so you don't want to be dependent on
generating randomness
a nice way to model it is okay have some
initial event where you've you're
putting in random numbers and you're
storing them and then from then on you
want everything to be deterministic then
you don't have to rely on random number
generators how so it's really good idea
to use this and I use it my software
most most things use this kind of
standard however you can't verify that
anyone's actually using it it's purely
internal it's a you know internal way
for you to make your own signatures but
no one can actually you can't prove can
you prove no you I'm not gonna say you
can't prove you're using it but you not
not in any reasonable fashion yeah so no
one knows if you're doing it so so this
is an attack where you can say okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna make a whole bunch of
different signatures they're all gonna
be valid but that will mean I've got a
whole bunch of different transactions
that are doing the same thing so maybe
the question is what does this really do
does this really hurt if someone you
know dots an eye on your check it's the
same amount it's going to the same place
sort of who cares right outputs are the
same then puts it's pointing to are the
same it's just this like you know sort
of annoying thing okay I tweaked it and
I change the TX ID no big deal well in
some ways yeah it's no big deal but a
lot of wallets didn't deal with this
well right so you let's say you're
running a wallet you make a transaction
and you sign and you broadcast
transaction to d5 in CAC and it never
gets confirmed and instead someone out
there flips a bit changes your
transaction to 9c be a 3e and that gets
confirmed and your wallet just says yeah
this this transaction you sent never got
confirmed there's there's waltz that did
that most of them have fixed it by now
but but if you're thinking of
transaction IDs as the you know identity
you know TX ID this is this is the name
of the transaction I I create it I'm
watching it to make to see when it gets
confirmed and I'm not looking for
something some maleate adverse I'm just
watching this thing that I created never
gets in a block weird and it's just
stuck in the wallet so they're
definitely wallets I think everyone's
fixed it by now but a couple years ago
definitely wallets that would have these
problems
you know it's a wall problem right your
money your money got to the right place
you just need to sort of either delete
stuff in your wallet or upgrade the
software or tell it to somehow forget
about this transaction and actually look
on the blockchain for everything similar
to your transaction but it did do some
damage um I think so
you know 2014 the like mount GOx thing
where mount GOx got hacked suppose you
know and lost all the money they blamed
transaction malleability which was kind
of interesting there may have been an
attack on my ox that used transaction
malleability the the trends the the
attack probably was this which was um
you know login to mount cox withdraw
some coins modify the TX ID to this and
then you know it gets confirmed you get
your coins and then login to my ox and
say hey this never happened my
withdrawal didn't work and then their
system would automatically issue a new
withdrawal transaction and so you could
just start taking all the money out and
you know your balance on the system it's
like when we keep trying to send you
money and it keeps getting never getting
confirmed and so we keep making new ones
I don't know to what extent that that
actually happened there's a lot of
contra you know it couldn't have it
couldn't have been the whole thing for
Mohawks definitely there's still a lot
of uncertainty about that but it does
show you know it's indicated if you
write your own software and it's not
accounting for these things you may be
losing money right once he hit people
say hey this didn't work make a new one
and then you keep doing that and losing
a ton of money but that's pretty sloppy
practices I think another issue if
you're spending from a unconfirmed to
change output or a none confirmed output
so you make a transaction you send the
two different outputs you've got a TX ID
and one you know you're sending five
coins to this person and three coins
back to yourself
those that three coins back to your self
output you might want to use it again
pretty quickly sometimes this happens
and so you've got a change output yes
you know from transaction once have
enough eec one
so you're gonna now
spend that change output however the TX
ID of transaction 1 changes so you're
you're saying where you're spending from
is no longer valid and this is a big
problem because now you've signed a
transaction that you think is gonna be
valid but the the money you thought you
were spending sort of moves out from
under you
and so that transaction is no longer
valid right tx2 is no invalid it refers
to something which can never be
confirmed because there's a you know
different transaction that's almost the
same but they're mutually exclusive that
did get confirmed okay so this is bad it
doesn't seem that that right and so for
years in Bitcoin this was a problem that
like wallets dealt with software and
people would like oh yeah you have to
like you know backup your keys
delete your whole database and like
resync the blockchain and then it'll
find the right transactions like you
know kind of hacky workarounds like that
where it didn't happen too much it
wasn't a wasn't a great attack right
like you can annoy people you don't get
any money so it wasn't a huge deal but
it was annoying but the idea is you can
always resize right you've got your
private keys if the money you are
receiving sort of shifts around and
changes its location well it's still
yours you just need to re-sign but what
if you can't resize so the case of
multi-sig where in most cases when
you're doing transactions if you just
have one key it's just you that's fine
in the case of multi-sig usually you're
all friends to some extent and you're
all in the same organization or you know
multiple devices that you own but but
you can have sort of adversarial
multi-sig where you're signing
transactions with people who were you
know you're sort of cooperating with
them but you might not really trust them
or they might be potentially attackers
things like that you can definitely sort
of extend your multi-sig model into that
and there could be multi-sig pre-signed
transactions where okay we've got this
two of three output address this this
output that exists and one of the two of
three has pre signed a transaction and
hands it over to me and then they
disappear I say oh okay well I'm gonna
now
sign my side but if malleability occurs
and the transaction ID changes that
signature is no longer valid all right
and signing something that's not there
anymore
so this is very important in payment
channels lightning Network stuff that
I'll get to in a few days and so so it
wasn't so much that malleability was
like a showstopper bug and everyone was
losing tons of money it was that it was
preventing kind of new cool things from
happening because there were a lot of
problems with okay I'm gonna you know
let's make this construction where we
put money into a multi sync account and
then I sign like a refund transaction
that's got a lock time before I actually
fund it and things like that where you
you couldn't reliably do it because if
either party modified their signature
they could break the whole thing and
they could have a tax where it's like
okay we're doing something together oh
look it's it got stuck well both of our
coins got stuck in this place hmm
now it's sort of a hostage situation and
you can say well I think I should get
one in half and you should get one you
know 0.5 it's like we both put in 1 so
so there's a tax that could happen and
so this malleability was a problem for
people trying to do new cool things so
how do you fix this any ideas non
malleable signatures so the one we did
for the first homework right does anyone
have an idea about why the Lamport
signatures were non malleable like from
problems that one yes that's right like
but yeah they weren't right you you
[Music]
there's no randomness for one I'm pretty
sure if you flip any of the bits it's
it's not gonna work so Lamport
signatures are an example where yeah
it's not malleable you can't produce
multiple multiple Signet and multiple
different signatures on the same message
so that's good the thing is many useful
signature schemes are malleable so to
just say no you have to use an
unreliable signature scheme it's not a
great answer to the question RSA I'm
pretty sure there's some weird
stuff in RSA ECDSA a lot a lot of the
systems have randomness in there and
they're malleable so an idea that I had
like 2014 and I was sort of going for
was just don't sign your inputs at all
only sign your outputs so you don't
actually specify where you're sending
money from in your signature you do have
to still specify it in your transaction
because people need to know but you you
say I'm only gonna sign off on the
outputs right the the sort of
endorsement of my inputs is implicit
because the keys match right so I don't
actually sign off on which key I'm
sending from just some stuff like that
that's redundant right you you know I'm
sending from these inputs because the
keys match up and the signatures valid
for this key I really like this idea
still I think it's really fun you can do
a lot of cool stuff with it it's also
dangerous it allows signatures to be
replayed which is sort of one of the big
points of having UT exos because if you
if you send two outputs so you know you
could send you know I have address you
know address one I send to two outputs
so I've got output 1 output 2 and they
this someone has five coins this one has
three coins and I you know they're both
the same
the boasts the same address both the
same public key and then I want to spend
and if I use this sort of signature
scheme where I don't actually sign which
input I'm spending from it can be used
on either so maybe I'm not aware of this
five one yet or it just hasn't happened
yet I haven't seen it and I say yeah I'm
gonna make a signature sending three
coins over here and then someone can
maleate the transaction without touching
the signature and pointing over here and
the signature would apply to either and
then this is a really good deal for the
miners because now I'm spending five
coins and only outputting three and the
miners get the two coins difference and
so that's you know pretty dangerous and
also even if they're the same i I just
say hey I'm sending three coins to you
and then as soon as the receiver sees
this output oh it'll also work here I'm
gonna
another three points so this is
mitigated by not reusing addresses but
people reuse addresses there's it's you
know so it is dangerous um I think in
the context of multi-sig you can
reliably say like okay we're not raising
addresses because these addresses are
the combination of multiple people
working together but it would allow
really cool things where you could sort
of work backwards compute a public key
that you could prove no one knew the
private key to but you could still sign
with it and like really weird crazy
stuff um anyway this never got in people
were still talking about it a week or
two ago like oh we can do these cool
things with it but it's it's dangerous
and so it's like you know we're not sure
if it's okay any questions about this
transaction malleability so far okay so
any ideas of what you actually do to fix
malleability nobody okay well okay we'll
find out in one minute segregated
witness I don't think is a good name
separate signatures would be a much
easier to understand name um
so Peter will who is really good at
Bitcoin and makes all these cool things
he's not the best at naming things makes
that's the cool stuff but just makes
whatever weird technical name so it's a
pretty straightforward idea the idea is
when you're when you're signing a
transaction you hash a bunch of data to
sign but you don't include the
signatures in the data you're hashing to
sign them right because that wouldn't
make any sense you can't do the same
thing when you're referring to
transactions themselves as T X IDs so in
the exact same way that when you're
signing you hash the data without the
signatures when you're pointing to a
transaction to say I'm spending from
there also don't include the signature
data you know just take the hash of the
signature without say take the hash of
the data without the signatures so yeah
you just sort of have this pointer do I
don't you know you've got a pointer to
another input and you've got the
puts where the signatures aren't in
there so the idea is the signature can
change in the transaction ID doesn't
okay but what about backwards
compatibility so this is a great idea
why not go for it but how do you make it
backwards compatible so that old
software can still work with it right
and it seems like you know a soft fork
is I'm adding new rules to the system
right I'm putting further restrictions
on this seems like just a change right
it seems like look I'm now calling thing
I'm now defining something in a
different way I'm removing the
signatures from the TX ID how do we make
this not appear to be a hard fork hard
Forks easy you just say look we're
changing the entire system from now on
TX IDs don't have signatures so any
ideas how you do this any backwards
compatible way or just give up hard work
right right so you can't change old
transactions but having both at the same
time is tricky the way you do it yeah so
the idea is it would have been easier to
start off this way right if Satoshi had
just started this way it would great he
didn't think of it it wasn't a super
obvious thing that you know so you knew
it as a soft work the way you do it is
you make new outputs which don't require
any signatures at all and then you just
don't have any signatures this seems
kind of silly signatures are pretty
important otherwise any arbitrary person
you just take all the money
but you redefine things in a way that
new people know about and old people
don't so this is actually what a segue
output looks like the output script is
just a zero and then a pub cash and then
the sync script you know the field for a
signature is just nothing you just don't
put a signature there and then when
you're running the stack you end up with
a punky hash on the top of the stack
which is some number and it's you know
the interpreter looks at a number that's
nonzero as true right I can see here
things like that I'm going to move it's
great
someone was joking that you could
potentially make this into a hard fork
because what if the punky hash was zero
and Segway you found the hash you found
a punky that hash to zero and then you
signed with it and it's a go it would
accept it but old no it's wouldn't they
actually that doesn't work but but it's
sort of a anyway so so this for old if
you're running the regular Bitcoin
software you see this and no signature
and you're like yeah this doesn't need a
signature right it's just a hash like I
don't know what this is fine
the coins move you know evaluates the
truth but the new version of the
software sort of adds a restriction to
this kind of output it says look if you
see this this is a template this doesn't
actually mean put a zero on the stack
and put a punky hash on the stack it
means something else now it means this
is a pub key hash and look for a
signature but look for a signature in a
different place don't actually put it in
the place you're supposed to put
signatures put in a new place that and
don't tell
the old software about this place we may
we add a new field to the transaction
inputs it's I don't it's in the wit it's
sort of in the inputs but they put at
the end it's kind of weird logically
it's in the input you know it's the same
but like physically it's not which is
which is silly I like that aspect of it
um but the idea is there's this new
field in the inputs called the witness
field and in cryptography witness
mathematics it sort of means signature
in this case anyway it's a little bit
more general but the old software never
sees it so the idea for here's the old
transaction format you've got your TX ID
and index you know 36 bytes sort of
pointer to where what you're spending
and then a signature which is a hundred
bytes this stays the same and the new
tax format the idea is ya the signatures
field still there you just leave it
empty right so you don't you're not
putting any signature it doesn't look
like you need to put a signature to the
old peep the old software and then you
have this you know third thing which is
witness which is the same as signature
basically slightly different format and
like technically they put them all
together and put at the end which is
kind of annoying but anyway logically
this is how they do it they make a new
version of the transaction format so the
old version looks like empty signatures
the new version looks like here's this
useless empty signature field and here's
where the real signatures are and you
omit the omit this to the old notes so
when people ask for witness transactions
when people know about this new system
yeah you give it to them so they say hey
yeah I'm I'm I'm hip to this new segment
thing give me a segue transaction and
you're like okay here's the witnesses at
the end but when they don't seem to know
about this and they're running older
software and they say hey just give me
the transaction you you give it to them
without the witness at all it still
looks valid to you know either one looks
valid right however the new people they
know that if you see this it does not
mean push a zero push up up key hash
there's a new rule that no this is a
template
this is segue I need a signature
I need it to be in the witness field so
if a new node gets a transaction without
a witness that they know needs a witness
they will declare it invalid but the old
nodes won't be able to distinguish
they'll say well it looks like you know
no signatures needed here okay so you're
you're sort of tricking the old software
into accepting things they shouldn't
actually accept in some cases right
there may not be a valid signature
that goes into the seg whit transaction
but old old software will still think
it's okay so this is how you make it
into a soft work it's kind of ugly but
yeah do you know because it's based on
the output script you could make you
could make a different output script
that would have a signature that no
signature requirement and it would still
work even with with this new system so
it's just based on you know we changed
the definition of an output script you
know so have this sort of template you
can still do which like you could put a
you could put without a zero in front
you could put just a pub key hash and
that's not defined inside what that's
not defined anywhere
it would just be okay yeah it evaluates
the true without a signature anyone can
spend it and you could do that that
would happen oh so that would have to be
a non segue transaction right the only
way to use a tag what transaction is to
have the special format for the output
script any other questions about network
stuff yeah so it's and in this solves
malleability in a pretty good way right
for the old software the old nodes well
they can't change the signature because
there isn't one there's nothing to
maleate and from the new nodes
perspective yes the signature can change
but that doesn't affect the transaction
ID both old and new nodes still agree on
the exact same transaction ID the
transaction ID does not include the
witness field right so when you're when
you're calculating the transaction ID
you
blew it all this for backwards and if
there's this actual signature there that
gets into the TX ID but if you're using
empty signature and only using witness
then it doesn't get into the TX ad at
all
um so both both old and new software
agree and that's important because if
they didn't the merkel roots would look
wrong right you take all the TX ids put
them into a merkel route put that in the
header um and that's really important
that everyone agrees on that so they do
they do work together so that's cool
yeah so this is kind of interesting
you've got two different sort of you
know old version new version operating
at the same time on the network and they
agree on a lot of stuff but they also
sort of disagree on some things right so
they agree on outputs of the
transactions and they agreed on which
inputs there are but they have a
slightly different view of what these
inputs are some of them think no
signature is here some thing yeah
there's a signature here that's weird
they don't agree on how things got spent
what are some other things that these
two different classes of nodes would not
agree on any ideas so you you you
understand like how they see different
transactions what are some other aspects
that may be sort of interesting for this
consensus system that we have different
views on I forget what I put I put two
things right any hint biggest argument
since 2010 in Bitcoin what do these two
different classes of nodes not agree on
yeah well the transaction size yeah so
they both see two different transactions
one of them sees it with these
signatures one of them sees it without
they don't agree on how big the
transaction is they agree on the TX ID
right they agree on where the money's
going where it's coming from but they
have completely different views of how
big this transaction is in terms of
number of bytes so this is really
interesting for many many years since
2010 everyone's been arguing and one of
the big aspects of oh we want to
increase the block size that
hard fork right everyone up to now you
know we're enforcing the block size must
be 1 million bytes or less there's no
way around that
right you can't just increase it that's
we've got this rule you're breaking that
rule this is a sneaky way to break the
rule but still not tell people you're
breaking the rule right say ok I'm
enforcing a rule that there's 1 million
bytes as far as I'm concerned there are
less than 1 million bytes in this trans
that in this set of transactions the new
nodes No yeah there's there's more than
a million there's like 2 million bytes
in here we just didn't tell the people
who you know we didn't tell the old
software about all these extra bytes so
this is kind of an interesting thing you
can do so you can increase the
transaction size without telling the old
notes so yeah the old notes don't see
the 100 something bytes with the pub key
signature so there they see transactions
that are much smaller around half the
size depends but half the size ish
so those bytes they won't count doors
those bytes towards the 1 million byte
block size limit so this is ends up
being a soft fork that allows you to
increase the block size in a kind of
sneaky way right the old nodes don't
think the block size has increased they
think it's less than a megabyte and they
also think this is weird I haven't seen
any signatures for a while everyone
seems to be using these transactions
that don't require signatures and
somehow everyone's getting along and not
stealing each other's money despite the
you know lack of a need for signatures
but you know these are not intelligent
people these are software programs and
if you you know it'll just run ok yep
yep yep you know this evaluates the
truth so it's kind of cool block size
entry soft work however you Institute a
new rule with segue you don't want to
just say we don't count for the new
rules we don't count signatures turns
them on megabyte limit right you could
do that but then people might spam
signatures right let me make a giant
signature or some kind of like 50 out of
a million pub keys thing and spam the
network and then it will still be under
a megabyte of nah
witness data but so yes and I've got two
classes of data you got all the data
that everyone sees and all the witness
data that only the new notes see so you
what they did is they said okay the
witness data still counts towards that
limit but it counts each witness bite
counts as 1/4 of a regular bite okay
kind of weird
yeah so in practice in the software what
they do is they say okay we multiply the
non witness bites by four so every every
output every button the outputs and
everybody liked exid inputs things
constants like 4 bytes and then the
witnesses just count as one regular byte
and then we now say okay the new block
size is 4 million bytes but they don't
for a million weight units because
they're sort of okay we've sort of got
different weights for things this
actually makes sense because the you TXO
set is what you were really want to
minimize right that database we keep
updating every block and the signatures
don't go into the ut Exocet right so the
signatures you don't actually have to
store on like a fast low latency storage
so how so in a very real sense the
signatures are sort of okay to make
bigger they don't really cost as much to
the network to store
so having this discount where you say
okay the the signatures you can have a
bunch of them that doesn't really count
as much but the outputs we really need
to minimize so this this 1/4 is like
somewhat arbitrary but there are some
calculations or like a little hand wavy
but it's like yeah this is about what it
should be to sort of try to balance
thanks ok so the end result if you've
got if you have this discount you can
put about 80% more transactions in a
block you get about 1.8 Meg's
it depends right it depends how big your
signatures are so the maximum would be
you have a block that has one
transaction with just a giant signature
that's like almost 4 megabytes and the
old software would see this block as
being really tiny like 100-something
bytes and the new software would see oh
yeah this block is almost 4 megabytes
but that's sort of the extreme case I
remember generating some like 3.7 meg
Tran
actually two blocks I'm testing that a
while ago just to test it out it works
but in practice you seen about this um
and in practice today as segment has
been you know seeing more adoption you
see like 1.3 megabyte blocks you know
not everyone's using it you know the
idea is it's it's backwards compatible
you can still use your old software but
it seems like more and more software is
using this you get a discount on your
fees because your transaction seems to
be smaller right you can fit more of
them in a block so it's kind of cool and
that's sort of an incentive to use it
okay
other thing you can do you can commit to
signatures this is a little tricky if
the signatures aren't in the transaction
ID then they aren't in the merkel route
right so there's nothing really
committing the signatures into the
blockchain and this would actually work
you could say no i have a signature i'll
give it to you but it could change right
it could mount it can be malli ated so
it could be weird though right you could
agree on a UTI Exocet when you could
have disagree on how exactly you've got
there so one example would be um
multi-sig where there's two of three
multi-sig Alice Bob and Carol two of
them need to sign and then on my
computer it says that Alice and Bob
signed and on your computer it says that
Allison Carol signed that's weird
right like we're not you know for
accountability if we want to know who
who exactly endorsed these things we
might disagree on it there's there would
be no canonical like here's the
blockchain here's who signed the
transactions themselves would all still
be the same but not the signatures so
that's kind of weird but it also seems
that well maybe that's part of the price
you pay for fixing malleability in this
way right if we're not if we're not
putting the signatures into the like
sort of thing that gets committed to in
the blockchain
then yeah signatures can change so any
way around this seem it sort of seems
like yeah that's the trade-off right
it's easy way around it
sneaky fun you know okay so what you do
actually
you know you commit the signatures but
in a weird way okay so here's the
regular old Merkel tree right this is
the Merkel route that you put in the
header here's all the transaction IDs
and so you make these intermediate
hashes you know this is the hash of
these two things concatenated together
this is a hash of these these things
concatenate it together um
now if the TX IDs don't have signatures
yeah there's no commitment to the
signatures in the top hash well you use
this say okay I'm going to make these
new witness TX IDs hashes of
transactions that do include the
signatures in practice you could just
make a hash of just the signatures that
would also work they just they just take
the whole thing and now I've got this
sort of like other reflected Merkel tree
kind of thing where okay I take the hash
of these two witness transact
transaction IDs put it here and this one
just drops down you know it's another
Merkel tree and then you get a root for
all those things call it the witness
root and then what you do is you put the
witness root in the coinbase transaction
put it in an off return and the idea is
the coinbase transaction doesn't have
any signatures anyway right so you can
put it in there that you don't need to
include the transaction zero in this
witness tree
wait they do though right but they say
they like say that no maybe this is
slightly inaccurate in that I think they
actually do make a witness TX ID for the
coinbase transaction but they define it
as being zero or something so it's like
weird right but you could do that they
define a zero or they like that you pick
anything you want I'd have to look at
the code but anyway um the basic idea is
for these anyway you take the hash of
the whole thing including the signatures
put it in the witness route put the
witness root in the coinbase transaction
and the coordinates transaction gets in
to the merkel root so you are committing
to all the signatures but on the block
level not the transaction level right so
you don't so in the case where
I think Alice and Bob signed oh I think
Allison Carol signed you can have those
two transactions floating around on the
network and we can you know they have
the same TX ID and so who knows which
ones getting into a block there they
look almost the same many you know some
of the software won't be able to pick
between them however once it gets into a
block one of them will be committed to
it's like Oh ended up being here Allison
Carroll that actually you know those two
signatures actually got into the
blockchain however you could then yeah
you could you could prove hey no I had
this Alice Bob signature but then it
never got into the blockchain and maybe
you made it after the fact it never gets
committed to a bunch of pool software
doesn't do this what do you mean
haven't implemented as in they just
don't support Segway or okay wouldn't
that just not work right how but to the
new software if you don't have so what's
tepid okay well will it when one of the
rules in say so segue to the soft work
right you say okay we define these new
transaction types we define the sort of
template where if you have a zero and
then this punky hash it also says I
require every coinbase transaction and
every I require the coinbase transaction
to have this output that says opera turn
a a 9c whatever this little random four
random bytes and then I'd required to
have the witness route in here so I've
seen that a lot yeah so a lot of the
yeah a lot of the software says I'm not
gonna do this you know if I see a say-so
the other thing that's nice segue
transactions to old software look
non-standard so I mentioned before that
there's you know standard issue rules
where this looks weird
I'm not going to mine it I'm not going
to relay it to my peers but if I see in
a block well okay fine
so segue transactions look very
non-standard right it looks like there's
no signature that's weird there's this
zero like you know what's going on so
yeah you can you can still run a minor
and just not even know about segue it's
a little dangerous because you might see
a block that is say what invalid but you
wouldn't know it and so you might try to
mine on top of it so there there are
some risks but in general most people
are doing the right thing you could
still mind without knowing about this
stuff so any quit any questions about
committing to the signatures oh yeah so
you got this upgrade path that's kind of
cool so it defined zero pub key hash as
hey this is now
this is now paid up up yes right
interpret this weird template as the
regular hey verify this signature
I also when when segue software happened
redefined a whole bunch of other
templates like this so you know one and
then some data or two and then some data
you know just put a number and then put
a bunch of data all of these are sort of
defined as future upgrades so if you see
a three block of data you now say yeah
okay I know that segment version three
my software will maybe pop up something
say hey people are using segway version
three
you're only aware of segue at version
zero but and you'll consider it
non-standard you won't relay it but if
it's in a block yeah sure and you don't
require any anything about the signature
you'll just say yeah whatever weird
witness data you provide for these
outputs I don't know how to interpret
them I'm just gonna let it all go
through what that means is it's you know
there's no witness needed if a witness
is provided you just ignore it can you
just think everything's fine this allows
easier upgrades you have sixteen new
versions to upgrade to yeah you don't
you don't require any you know specific
things about this so you can make new
scripts you can make a completely
different script interpreter you could
say okay we're gonna port EVM to Bitcoin
and I'll disable some of the op codes
that don't apply and you know have that
kind of thing have new smart contracts
so it's kind of a fun like yeah we will
you know and it's it's a nice easy
upgrade path you could have multiple
different things the code will be easier
you could do it don't do it today right
you could construct an output that's a
2-byte and then your pub key and send it
out there it will be probably stealable
by miners right because everyone else is
node will say yeah I don't know how to
interpret this yet there's no new knows
there's no rules about this yet okay let
me okay wait let me show you some segue
stuff okay so there's actually um
there's actually like nested segue
there's like an ugly like they should I
didn't like it but yeah so this is like
you know somewhat designed by committee
II there's also this is like 2016 right
so the other thing I was saying with
this I was like okay you've got this
witness to UX ID and I remember people
working on Segway and I said hey why
don't you make the transaction IDs a
Merkel tree of the inputs and outputs
instead of just the hash of everything
altogether then if you had a really big
transaction you could prove that an
input had been spent without sending the
whole transaction over and like I
thought that was a cool idea and then
when I to talk to people they're like
yeah Peter Todd already said that like
three weeks ago and whatever we're not
gonna do it like it's too late we
already coded stuff and that's that's
the sort of fundamental aspect of Segway
it you can't really upgrade that in the
new in the new script versions so
whatever there's also still a hard rule
and one transactions themselves being
less than to make what I think so it's
not a huge deal but it'll been cool
another thing is there's actually a way
so this this would there's no address
defined for this right addresses map to
output scripts in all the software and
so when you say okay I'm sending to one
AEC C or whatever it knows how to
interpret that address build the 20-byte
pub key hash script and send to it and
vice versa all right so from an address
you can get this output script and from
the output script you can get an address
so when a when a old software sees this
it's just like there's no address I
don't even know what that is I've never
seen that and so you you people worried
that like oh it's gonna be weird people
are gonna have to upgrade to even send
to people using segue right so it's
backwards compatible but if you want to
say hey send me some some money at this
eggwin address and then they can and so
you say okay fine send me the money with
a regular address and then we have still
have this malleability problem and then
i have a wallet that supports both and i
can move money to my own addresses and
kind of ugly so they made this like
nested address thing which I don't like
because then it actually it has both so
you've got a signature and a witness and
the signature is like not a real
signature it's just pointing to the
witness it's like really ugly there's a
bunch of weird stuff in a segue code
that like not I'm not super into I don't
have to use it though right that's the
beauty of these permissionless
innovation kind of systems like like you
I don't like that code okay I'm not
supporting it so okay so what just
happened okay okay so here's one that's
nested so I did I would just like
randomly looking through a block here's
one and you can see it's like okay the
output I'm not the outputs are probably
also nested seg wit and the input is you
know it's got both a script sig and a TX
witness write d-x
input with a sort of pure one is this
one f7 and okay so you can see the oh
wait am I not running what version am i
running I think I'm running fifteen one
still so I'm not seeing the address
there's a new address format called Beck
Beck 32 32 which will turn you know see
it's zero and then a pub key hash or no
sorry that's zero and then a script hash
zero and then a pub key - you know says
witness version zero key hash there's
also an address associated with these I
think this version of Bitcoin CLI does
not show it but the new version does so
I think if you guys have version Oh
point sixteen point oh it'll show like
here's the address and then you can see
in the input a single input for this
transaction there's a TX in witness and
there's no scripts that you know there's
a script sig field and it's just empty
there's no actual
traditionally there's instead this big
thing here's the signature and here's
the pub key being revealed and then it
also says okay here's the TX ID without
the signature and then here's the hash
or witness transaction ID the hash of
the whole thing including the signature
and they're different right also you've
got size so this is actually 235 bytes
right because you're including the
witnesses and then V size which is
virtual size this is how big it looks to
old software that doesn't know about
segue so the new software this this
knows about both right okay the actual
size or witness size is 235 be size is
135 53 so yeah it's not quite not you
know 50% I don't know because this one
has two outputs and the outputs don't
get any smaller and the input just get
smaller and then size V size and then
you can see what block it's in let me
get the coinbase transaction okay so the
first transaction in the list is gonna
be the coinbase transaction and I can
get that one and okay so yeah the
coinbase transaction has a different TX
ID and hash it's size is 259 it's V size
to 32 coinbase has whatever anybody they
want and there's the actual output which
is sending to this address and it's
sending 12.7 nine coins and then there's
this zero value output so you can have
an output that's got a amount of coins
set to zero still okay and it's got this
opportunity and the opportunity a twenty
one a 9e d and those four bytes mean
here's this here's the segwayed
commitment here's the witness commitment
to the segue transaction hashes the root
of all those and you have to have that
right in order to have a valid segue
block and so then we can you know this
is this is segue and action I think most
blocks now will have that
it's also got really so there was size
and V size right and that sort of makes
sense but then you have strip no V sizes
not strips up it's really confusing and
I like size weight height what so size
is I don't actually know I think size is
interpreted same this is the actual
number of bytes for this block weight is
you multiply all non witness bytes by
four and you leave all witness bytes as
weight one and that has to be less than
four million and you can see here it's
just under formulate and then stripped
size is the size that old nodes see yeah
pretty sure anyway so it's it's kind of
confusing and one of the biggest
problems in bitcoin is like names where
it's like weights script pub key and
like script sink script like like all
these terms and names are just really
confusing and it's sort of getting worse
so yeah they these are not also it's
like there's no V sized yet I think any
I think this is actually anyway so
that's how say what works in the actual
thing but it's nice because now you can
reliably spend from things before
they're confirmed so say quit school
fixes malleability increases the block
size oh it does a whole bunch of other
stuff too okay so one of the aspects
that it fixes when you're signing a
transaction not saying you have five
inputs each time you sign you need to
hash the whole transaction because it's
slightly different right you zero out
all the signature fields but on the
signature field for the one you're
actually signing you don't zero it out
you put the previous public key you put
the previous script they're also
slightly different it's it's totally
redundant there's no reason to put it
there because it's already in the TX ID
but you change things along on a little
bit so the idea is so I'm gonna put a
signature here I'm gonna put a signature
here put a signature all five of them
each time I put a signature here I hash
the transaction right to get us
slightly different thing design for each
one it might not jump out at you but
this is actually
oh and squared this bad right
because the idea is as I extend the
number of signatures required in a
transaction the number of inputs in a
transaction the amount of data that
needs to be processed goes up with the
square of the number of inputs right
because I add an input now the total
size of the transaction gets bigger so
each time I sign I need to take a bigger
amount of data through my hash function
also the number of signatures gets
bigger all the number of it so this is N
squared it seems fine right you never
knows except when you do so so there's
like pathological block there was one
like 2015 early in the year where some
minor was like I'm gonna make this block
that's one giant transaction with like
thousands and thousands of inputs and a
lot of software choked on it and like it
took gigs of RAM to process the
transaction and things like that so that
was bad just in general if you have a
lot of little dust outputs and you're
trying to aggregate them into one big
you know I'm gonna have hundred inputs
and one output it takes forever to sign
and it also takes forever to verify so
it's you know it's pretty bad I remember
sort of silly story Tim Draper's coins
yeah all this dust and I was it was like
nerve wracking because it was like way
more money than I'm gonna make in my
life and like moving Tim Draper's coins
to somewhere else and the software by
default just swept all the inputs right
then with that wallet controlled and
they were looking at me they're like why
doesn't this work like was it frozen I'm
like no I'm not trying to steal the
money guys because he had like everyone
is sending all these little outputs to
Tim Draper's like 30,000 coins and
remember because he's and the way I
tried to spend it it took like five
minutes to sign yeah so this is yeah
it's it's bad right any any o of N
squared this is sort of a bug egg would
actually fix this the way they do it is
they say okay we sort of pre compute
these three intermediate hashes right
take the whole transaction
this is sort of the global transaction
data and like precompute these three
things and then for each of the inputs
add another thing right here's this
input specific so this is like global
it's it's like the hash of all the TX
ends the hash of all the outputs the
hash of this and then here's the the
input specific specific and then you
know hash all these things into one one
thing and then sign that so the idea is
it's over in that like you compute these
three and then you sort of go down keep
changing this for each one so that saves
a lot of time it's a much nice oh you
also put in you also put in the amount
being spent in your signature hash which
is also redundant right because that's
committed to in the TX ID that you're
selling but it's really nice for
hardware wallets because a lot of times
hardware wallets are essentially
presented with here's a hash sign it and
they have you know it's it's a very
small system you know it's a little chip
somewhere it doesn't really know too
much about Bitcoin it's just here's a
hash sign it okay and they don't know
how much they're spending so there could
be a tax on Hardware wallets where again
a hardware wall to sign something where
it's actually moving too much money so
it's nice to be able to like have the
actual amount in there so there's a
bunch of stuff like that
there's a it was sort of a giant grab
bag of like all these different little
fixes things like that fixes
malleability it increases the block size
does all these other cool things people
didn't like it
never really understood why
all these reason wait
he seemed like good things right what
that wasn't what it wasn't like people
were like oh here's some little things I
don't like about it cuz that was what I
said that was like what everyone working
on Bitcoin was like no one no one was
like thinks it's perfect right it was
like but what if this thing is weird why
did you do that or why didn't you put
this in kind of things but no the people
who didn't like it really didn't like it
you know there were there's still a
bounty on sippers head right there's you
know death threats someone's like I'll
pay someone to kill this guy that you
know that it's all this is going to
destroy Bitcoin that you know say gwit
isn't bitcoin anymore because there
aren't any signatures it's like no
signatures they're still committed to
just in a different way right you have
to build this other tree and so lots of
weird conspiracy I know it became like
this really sticking point and so that
sort of led to Bitcoin cash the whole
idea is like Segway is bad we're making
Bitcoin cash and Bitcoin cash forked off
before seg what activated in in the main
network interestingly Bitcoin cash uses
this so they took a bunch of the code
from Segway because you know this is a
really good signing the improvement to
signing the cashews but they didn't like
Segway yeah I'm still not like I don't
know I I there's problems I have with it
too but it's you know it's an upgrade
and that's cool I think a lot of it was
people wanted a hard fork this was a
software and so there was backwards
compatibility and they wanted to sort of
show that people have more control over
Bitcoin that they want the name maybe do
it might never be possible to have a
hard fork to get everyone on board to
like really switch so who knows so yeah
it was interesting it took forever and
that was the last change to the McLin
code in terms of like consensus code and
that would it was initially announced
late 2015 in Hong Kong it's and then all
of 2016 and never XO it activated what
oddest of last year and now you can use
it
yeah yeah so on your convert coin you're
like I'll just take the segment code and
activate it and like cool and then
people trying to stop it and spend a lot
of money to stop it I sorta okay another
okay I don't I want to say unclear why
cuz I don't know it's sort of weird
there's a whole lot of opinions one
theory is that this breaks some mining
chips optimizations one of the
optimizations these it doesn't work with
a tree of height too but if you have a
really tall tree you can swap TX IDs or
you can swap intermediate nodes of the
tree and you'll get a different merkel
root right so you you can see if like if
I like so it doesn't work here because
this has to stay in place right but in
many cases the order of the transactions
is arbitrary right so I could I can flip
these to it's still valid right so what
I might do is say okay I have this
merkel root a mining and then i want to
flip these to calculate a different
merkel root in mine and there were some
chips that maybe did this and had these
kinds of optimizations there was also
like a patent on it and all this weird
stuff going on it break it doesn't break
but it essentially loses the
optimization if you have this right
because you say okay i'm gonna have this
big tree i'm gonna swap something near
the top and they only has to recompute
like two hashes to get a numerical route
however if i'm if i now have this sort
of mirror image witness Merkle tree
underneath if i say okay i'm gonna swap
this I'm also swapping all these and I
have to recompute this right maybe I can
swap some of it but I have to recompute
what this is this is gonna change it
just as well and then I have to put that
in here and this is gonna be at the
bottom and then I'm gonna have to
recompute everything all the way up to
the Merkel rate so this was called ASIC
boost and then there was a post no Craig
Maxwell posted like this sort of like
you your guys like accusatory mail and
the mailing list last spring
saying look we were trying to figure out
a way to break a sick boost because we
think miners have this like patented
algorithm that optimizes and it gives
you know 20 to 30 percent speed-up and
we're worried that the patents will make
you know one miner have a monopoly and
be everyone else won't be competitive so
we're trying to think is there a way we
can sort of make software to prevent
this from this optimization and then
once they tried to look at it they're
like oh wait
Segway does that you know we want to
make it costly to swap things in the
tree and say what does that oh so
basically we're already we're good and
then he was like oh wait maybe that's
why all these people hate Segway
maybe this is you know these these
miners who have you know billions of
dollars worth of equipment with these
optimizations in it which would be
rendered you know unusable by this new
software change maybe they're trying to
prevent it from activating it's a theory
and you know that the mining company
said no that's that's a bunch of
nonsense
although the way they said it was sort
of suspicious like yeah we we put
circuitry in our chips to do this but we
never used it strange so so who knows
but yeah that's one theory I'm not sure
how much I believe that's the real
reason but
yeah because the order matters because
when you validate like this transaction
might create an output that this
transaction spends and so if you swap
them yeah so if you didn't have inter
inter intra block dependencies then it
would all be arbitrary and you could put
it ordering but there are intra block
dependencies and so the order does
matter in many cases it doesn't right in
many cases these are two separate
transactions you can swap them but the
the software does use the ordering so
yeah there's also all sorts of other
things would be honor what I would want
is prepend or append the height at each
stage of the Merkle tree that would have
helped me out for some things because
then it's like you know since you're at
the bottom just put a zero at the end of
each hash and then when you get up here
put a one at the end of each hash easy
that you know doesn't really change
anything but one problem is what if I
request so what I wanted to do in my
software I want to request all the
transaction IDs in a block I don't
actually care about the transactions I
just want to see all the TX IDs you know
the way like this right if I get rid of
the head 20 I get giant list of TX IDs
the thing is and what this will let me
do is to look for transactions if I have
at exid I know I'm looking for so I'm
going to look for it in here
the problem is what if the person I'm
asking is giving me this instead of this
I won't know right they all look like
random numbers if I if I do the Merkle
tree I'll go I'll get to the merkel root
it's good but I don't really know that
I'm at the bottom unless you know in
it's ok and if I'm running a full node
and I'd actually download all the
transactions and look and ok it works
but have a to have a way to say hey give
me a list of all the TX IDs and I can
verify that it's correct I can't do that
right now there's ways around it but it
would have been nice if then they
appended a zero or something or even all
you have to do is just append something
at the bottom row where just append the
higher zone then it would've been kind
of cool would've been easier for me but
well they're there and there's people
who've written about this yeah
pool operators are leaving off the
waiver and if so does it weaken the
whole system it's I think what they
really do is they just don't support
Segway so I've seen especially like yeah
they say they're gonna support it and
then they don't so these are sort of
flagged their transactions yeah Segway
and then they haven't actually upgraded
their software so they can't use it they
can't mine it so you see this a lot on
Testament as well if you're making test
net seg wit transactions sometimes they
just don't get confirmed for a few hours
because all the blocks that come out
don't support it and so they won't use
it no no it's it's it hurts the
usability right if I want to use a
Segway transact but as me running a
Segway compatible node I require
signatures I require all this this whole
construction if you make a sec is
something that looks like it spends a
Segway transaction without this I just
reject it so security wise it's fine yes
important you know the way that these
things are designed in particular that
software design is that anyone who
doesn't update to the new functionality
can't hurt the security of the new
that's part of the design process
although their security might get hurt
right just not not a ton but yeah if you
if you haven't upgraded you might see
these Segler transactions and they they
look
yeah they look weird but you're like
okay fine but you can't actually verify
the whole thing right you might you
given a invalid and a valid Segway
transaction the old software can't
distinguish for the new software can't
support it it just you have to wait
until someone that does support it mines
a block yeah so if they if they try to
support it and support it wrong you you
ignore them you you know you don't use
their data you don't use their block
yeah so so I think in Bitcoin now it's
okay test nuts kind of weird but like
there's segue party and you can see what
people are doing with Segway but so yeah
it's about 30 this is by transaction
it's somewhere on 30 something percent
of the transactions are using Segway and
then you can see witness size percentage
block size okay so sometimes you go oh
wow I had no idea
blocks are way under a megabyte now oh
okay well free free transactions for
everyone
you want to use Bitcoin now's the time
you know to pay anything that looks very
different a month ago where you had a
solid red line yeah I sort of you know
nothing went below a million and then
you had a little bit of Segway at stuff
going on here but now you've got like
most things in below a million so
interesting okay so yeah so that's a the
basic idea of Segway and if people have
any questions
stick around ask there's office hours
tomorrow at four to six over there look
at the homework and next time I'll talk
about lightning Network payment I'll try
to get into payment channels and see how
far we get into lightning Network stuff